Hey guys,
Tim Ferriss here.
I'm going to talk a little bit about
what my breakfast might look like,
which isn't always a breakfast.
So I do experiment with
intermittent fast and quite a bit,
but this is kind of the basic lineup
and very typically if I'm say doing some
form of athletic training at 10:00 AM.
So I'm doing technical training right
now with gymnastics effectively at 10:00
AM then a train again in the union.
I will not have a large breakfast
but I will have a number of things.
The first is some form of ketone,
so synthetic or exogenous ketone or I
will have MCT oil which is converted very
readily into ketones by the liver.
So we have a couple of options here.
This is one, this is Quito
force from Quito sports. Uh,
this was introduced to me by Dominic
D'agostino scientists quite a while back,
but also a developed or could develop by
Patrick Arnold who is very world famous
black market biochemist.
Some might say, uh,
for performance enhancing compounds and
a key to force as well as even MCT oil.
And this is just, this is brain octane,
which is easy to find by bulletproof,
but there are many different types
is effectively caprylic acid,
c eight and you can find different
types. Perillo also has one. And uh,
this type of ketone accomplishes
a few things. Uh, in,
in my research based one I've seen it
can decrease the speed of tumor growth
even if you're consuming,
uh,
what you might consider a
Gluco genic foods, right?
So if you're eating a
carbohydrate inclusive diet
or co carbohydrate based diet,
these can still have an effect also
decreases oxygen requirements. Uh,
for endurance work has some
applications to anaerobic work.
So I will very typically have say three
capsules of this with a little bit of
lemon juice cause it's very,
very alkaline in water, right?
So it'd be option number one.
Option number two would be
say a capful of the c eight.
This is something you
want to work up to a,
otherwise you will get disaster
pants. So really work your way up. Uh,
the next is,
uh,
I will sometimes have a protein shake
in the mornings and it is currently
composed of this.
So we have terrorists way,
which is a goat whey protein unflavored.
I can stomach unflavored whey protein.
Not Everybody can. I will very often
combine that with this gelatin.
So Great Lakes Gelatin,
which is a Collagen hydrolysate
thump announcing that correctly.
I don't know, but I've read it
a lot. Haven't said it much.
This was introduced to me by Amelia Boone,
the world's most successful
female obstacle course racer.
I had an orange,
a jar version of this,
which is not a hydrolyzed and it's
disgusting. It doesn't mix well.
This mixes very easily
in cold or hot water. Uh,
so this however also tastes
a bit like cow hooves.
So I will combine the goat whey
protein to be two scoops of this,
a few tablespoons of the Collagen,
and then I will use a
tablespoon of the super beets,
which is the same as beat elite.
So they are,
they're the same product effectively.
So super beets or beat elite,
which has the added benefit of
some potential endurance, uh,
improvements. And I've written about
this on the blog before for our blog.com.
Uh, and if, uh, for for maybe
10% of the guys out there,
we'll have a very small but
noticeable Viagara like effect.
So you have that going to run
around the gym with a big boner.
Maybe this is good insurance to
have in your morning kit. Uh,
then we have the last piece of
this is a very consistently tea.
So I tend to brew tea along
these lines. I use this, this,
this Cuisinart kettle there many
electric kettles you can use.
I typically set it to
one 85 is my default,
but you have one 75 for green,
one 85 for white, one 94 Ulaan,
uh, 200 for French press, et Cetera.
But I will combine very often
this currently Ascensia in it.
And this is kind of my secret closet here.
Not so secret,
but it has two drawers
lest I mixed them up.
This is decaf. Uh, so I have white sage,
I have Douglas Fir,
Chai, Roy bus, et cetera.
And then I have all of
my caffeinated options,
which would include the
cub would say Sencha,
which is what I currently have in there.
And this was also a gift from Japan.
And then, uh, and this will be sacrilege,
do a lot of folks out there. Uh,
I will have some type
of poo air or oolong.
This is a roasted oolong tea.
Uh,
and I will just drop in,
really eyeball it.
And again,
there are purists who would just
be disgusted with this approach,
but I'm not a purist.
So there you have it and I'll drop this
in and the first step is generally very,
very short,
but I will leave it in there for
probably a good minute because one of my
objectives is getting the catechins
and caffeine and so on that is in here,
the theophylline, which is one of the
stimulus and green tea, et cetera.
And this also combines very nicely
with this or some type of butter.
So I will occasionally use
Kerrygold butter, uh, in t after I
have poured it into some type of Mug.
And that is effectively
the most basic breakfast.
But what I have noticed is that I perform
best when I have a little bit of food.
And this right here is wild planet
sardines packed in olive oil. So I,
we'll drizzle some of this olive oil on
my dog's food and then I will eat the
rest and including the oil.
And that is effectively right now my
micro breakfast kit as you see it here.
There are other times if I'm trying to
increase muscle mass substantially for
where I will have a very typical slow
carb breakfast with lots of eggs,
lentils, spinach, and whatnot.
But this is another alternative.
Have you heard of five bullet Friday?
Well, if you haven't, that's good news.
I'm excited because it is
my most exclusive content.
It is free and you can
check it out right here.
Lots of actionable
tactics, tools, and more.